[Music]
you want to start by saying it is
I was about to curse it is awesome to
see the two of you sitting together I
actually can't believe it because I grew
up reading your books I was there like
with the beginning of spawn and with the
thank you sir at the beginning of
everything so the fact that you guys are
together here and I'm time doing this is
like kind of one of those are you effing
kidding me moments you know now we get
to jump in so I saw you on the floor
yesterday and it's actually very fitting
you guys are together because it's
sideshow there is a toy venom pool yes
and it's a combination of haven't seen
it it's sauce is it right I drew a
couple covers with venom pose I'm like
I'm not gonna pass this up oh yeah what
the kids bedroom and Deadpool but that's
like dynamite oh it's dad Ewan it's it's
Todd Robbie right no I mean with the
kids love it's like it's like peanut
butter and chocolate place here's the
thing I think that it's very fitting
that that toy is here and the two of you
are sitting here and so I'm gonna start
with when was the last time you guys did
an interview together never I don't know
can't think about some Emerald City we
did a panel with the other image guys
but I mean I just look I mean ILI's jump
the point I get really reflective and
emotional or on San Diego I love this
show I love my memories I literally the
older I get the more I love comics the
more loved that I've been in comics and
I don't think there's some memory I have
without this this guy like especially
the formative years were the best they
were the craziest before we all became
our own entities it was so awesome and
and here's the thing that's great about
Rob I'm gonna I'm the Rob has the best
stories in the best memory right so I go
if you think I got stories and I've got
some good ones I go you got to go to you
got to go to rob to fill it in because
Rob I just know like the big stuff that
like the five styles and foot sort of
view of law Rob knows all the little
small steps that go in there and his he
talks and he tells some of those stories
then all of a sudden I get flashbacks
going oh that's right that's right now
and I'm going back 20 30 years because I
hadn't remembered it so I don't know
he's got a different brain on
what he remembered compared to what I
remembered so Steven or just a crazy
tribe I really believe our era our our
group the image guys we were just a
tribe that were all ritalin kids I don't
know just like crazy hyper active
aggressive alpha dogs
they're usually settled down as you can
see here's nothing that I think that the
story of how of what you guys did and
he's and I know there's been talk about
this but like they're like a movie
script out there or the story I'm sure
there's another one I wrote one who I
wrote one I tell you and if it ever got
made Academy Award plays Todd McFarlane
would win the Academy Award would win
I'm like I will sit there I hopefully
I'm invited if it's it you know and I'll
watch that guy go up there and go I just
wanted that one of the best Todd the
Todd voices to me tells a story I can
use all tonight he's also got the the
Eric's okay Eric Larson's okay with my
pair thinks he's better than here's what
I'm saying I think Rogers gonna agree
here I think they need to do an image
show like a TV show because when I've
talked to people in Hollywood by ago
this is all true right so everything
we're about to tell you is true based on
truisms and I go what show do you have
right now with pop culture being as big
as it is in which you can say words like
venom Deadpool spawn Batman Stanley
spider-man x-men cable like what and and
that's part of our vernacular as we're
having these conversations that's not a
script that show that's a show based on
the reality of these people who had some
impact on creating some of these
characters that are now sort of renowned
to be able to sort of see the beginning
of that process some of these characters
come to life and then just like any
other boy band some of the conflicts
that went through for us and again
because we were young we could drama
drama we were young foolish kids that
basically got too much too fast like a
lot of rock-and-roll bands right and so
I got all of this I go this is you're
looking for a show I shut there
sometimes go I don't understand why
people are
are do all the things you guys I mean
that and by the way I can't even imagine
what would have happened if social media
was around back then it wouldn't happen
that's uh but that's another story
you know because no but you guys got
four people that don't realize how old
were you when image comics was happening
because you were pretty young
I think I'm 23 23 why that young I'm not
so three or 20 so 1991-92 image is 27
years old well you know when you were
born so getting into age I'm 30 you were
much younger though but I'm talking
about like a few but you had you guys
had okay so that works
Wow I know you know and trust me I meet
23 year olds now and I go oh my god it
was such a dumb ass I can't believe I
was doing right in charge that guy in
charge I would yeah I mean literally
well you're basically what you're saying
oh my goodness we are the best behind
the music that could ever be moving ever
right behind the comic and also that the
thing that's interesting I agree with
you by the way it's much better as a TV
show than a movie just because you can
really get into personalities and really
get into it but you know you don't want
the movie the TV show gets you you get
the bacon because then eventually as you
move through this process all of a
sudden you go through it and then as the
project goes away then Rob Liefeld sort
of exit stage left a little bit Gimli
and then here comes Robert Kirkman stage
right like and it just keeps going right
you keep getting these stories that are
going right so it's so image is a
27-year story
it's Mad Men it's Mad Men with comics
who's John Hamm okay yeah we're good
that was an advertising agency or combo
company come on man good stuff good
stuff I want to jump Oh Danny DeVito is
he available
yeah I want to jump all the way back do
you guys remember what is the first
comic or some of the early comics you
read that said oh my god I love this
this is like the greatest thing ever for
me I I tell everybody I it's like right
there barbershop
ask for 147 Prince Namor charging out of
the ocean the thing on Iraq
so Submariner I'd never encountered a
Marvel comic before my parents had me
they let me read Richie Rich in Casper
but my barber fred god bless him he saw
the more and now I realize Hercules
Namor Wolverine
all these guys had temper problems and
they were my favorite guy I think I was
like angry kid meet angry haircut
characters I like the angry guys you
know Prince Namor I left on the thing I
mean it's awesome it's such a great
comic at the end of it sue storms like
I'm leaving you read it's the best comic
and as a kid you're like I need to have
this and it was seven or eight he
allowed me to trade like three Casper's
and Richie Rich she said Rob I'll give
you this but I need something in return
because I need to have comics for my
clients that set me on a course that I
would never come back from Wow so and
for me it was it was it was visual stuff
right because it made because I'm an
artist so I'm I was visual stuff Jorge
Perez at this time was doing the
Avengers and the Fantastic Four
both those boy I mean if you look at the
detail of Jorge Perez did to do both
those book and their team books which
team books already insane but to go I'm
gonna do two team books I'm going okay
and at that era he was doing is about
like Avengers 161 it was the attack of
the head man remember the head man came
go you can't walk me out of the
headquarters because I can go through
the air vents and it was this cover
where the ants were coming all over the
Avengers I go look at all that stuff and
about that same time maybe within a
month or two the Fantastic Four of what
Joe Senate was the best thinker on that
book so he was inking George for us
there's a shot of the fantasticar and
it's a two-page spread and they're
flying going we got to go someplace and
he's flying and Ultron you didn't know
it at the time shoots a bolt up and
blows a fantastic car apart in midair
and this two-page spread you could look
at it for a day and not get bored with
it and I just want Wow like and then I
met a little bit later and that meeting
George Prest a real man to see the human
doing it gone so it's doable to just
give this much power and energy because
at that point I didn't know who Jack
Kirby was and some of the some of the
prose you know that we're that it sort
of preceded this generation so it was
just the guys that were there and then
after that for me you know the John
Byrne's cup came in it's a lot of power
right that you just want oh my god burne
Miller Simonson Perez those are like our
our foundation that's the generation we
all you know grew up on what is there I
think I've asked maybe you guys this
question before but I'm gonna ask it
again there is an emergency you can only
grab one thing out of your place what's
the comic or the piece of art that is
like the thing that you always like the
prized possession
the thing that you know other fans would
dream about I'll go first
I got you I'm gonna I'm gonna give you a
two fold for comic books if I could only
if I gonna take one turn island one run
of comic books I take the 200 I don't
even mean a run no I'm gonna grab the
whole town I'm gonna grab the Compendium
done it's got the whole run
I'm gonna grab tomb of Dracula right
Touma Dracula was just so oddly
different to me and that every month
Gene Colan and Marv Wolfman and Tom
Palmer had this same look month in mouth
I go that was it I'd give away all my
superhero stuff for that so it doesn't
probably come and surprise it to me sort
of spawn is this dark sort of creature
now and be getting more monster because
I got a lot of monster stuff that I like
as a kid if it was one thing I could
grab shoot I've got an original page of
pencils from Jack Kirby that he gave to
me that he signed gone Todd good luck
young man and it was this this page oh
I'll see if I can go quickly on the
story I ain't a cover of Jack late in
his career and I inked over and then you
have to race the pages yeah
and I remember horrified that after you
after you erased it that what I had was
erasing was his pencils Jack King
Kirby's pencils it was his I know it
seems weird but it was a it was an odd
moment for me to know that those
shavings were Jack Kirby's pencils
it was blasphemy I saved those I saved
those shavings and in a little ziplock
bag a long time and I went oh my god so
then he phoned me back they said hey
Jack like what you did can you do
another one and I go under one condition
I've got to ink it on a vellum overlay
basically like tracing paper I
touch Jack Kirby I can't erase the
second pair yeah so idea go they said
yeah whatever
I do it bum-bum-bum a month goes by they
print it whatever else I get a phone
call Todd this is Jack I think Jack on
you I just want to say I like that that
that ink and you're doing over me and
I'm like oh my god because and I sent
you essentially something you're way not
an hour later FedEx rings I crack open
the box and I pull out it's the vellum
overlay that I had done he's given me
back my inks I reach in again it's the
original pencils that I didn't want to
touch with the with the signature on
there saying Todd you're a really cool
young man keep it going Jack and then
I'm going well oh my gosh and then on
top of it cuz that wasn't enough he goes
and I'm throwing in a Captain America
page from the Bicentennial one that
Barry windsor-smith inked on top of me
and you go what like that's it I can now
die so that would be it I'd grab that
Jack Kirby page I'm riddled with envy
and I can imagine everyone watching this
interview right now is like it riddled
with envy riddled for me the comics in
the are gonna match up uncanny x-men the
John Byrne run I can grab this many of
them yeah and and then I have a bunch of
pages from like my favorite page as a
kid when I came upon it and had a chance
to buy it I bought it and it's from the
Days of Future past story and it's
Wolverine and storm and they crawler and
it's this shot of Wolverine I drew so
many times the kid and I when I was like
I could own this this could be mine I
would grab that page and John Byrne
Terry Austin to this day if we're
talking 2d gritty I still believe
because I have so much most of my
original art collection that I have now
probably the majority of it is inked by
Terry Austin I just I I find that I'm
more of a Terry Austin guy and I'm
telling you Stephen
I think he came from the future taught a
generation that no one ink like him no
one came close and suddenly he used
tools and lines that no one saw before
bright everybody was a brush guy and he
was a pen guy yeah and not that that
chain and he the look and he literally
shaved his own he
would cut and shape his own nibs this is
legendary stuff I've asked him about it
he won't he won't he won't share those
secret to anyone which is why no one can
truly truly imitate him he was a mad
scientist but whether it was Frank
Miller whether it was John Byrne George
Perez most people go oh my favorite job
Terry Ossining somewhere along line he
just he Walt Simonson everyone he
touched so I have this uh I grab as many
of my Terry Austin pages but on the top
is the uncanny x-men 141 page that
that's a no-brainer
I'd agree to me burn Austin was the top
of the mountain you know I never I'm not
you guys are obviously wizards I
I never realized when I think back on
those runs and those issues I'm now
seeing that art in my head and I'm like
oh this explains a lot if you see it up
honestly if you can go in there and look
at Terry Austin I mean look at Tom
Palmer sinks look at everything the
anchors we're so much more important in
the 70s it for a varieties like a guy
like George Perez does to books because
they're three quarters of the way
penciled all the informations there but
then these fantastic anchors carry
across the line I mean we're into the
science of comics and I know Todd and I
we could get lost for hours how much we
love that stuff yeah I'm so let's stay
on Terry Austin for a moment and geek
out a little bit to me to define to just
go let's not talk about him I'll show
you how good he is take a look at Tom
Sutton's artwork grab as much Tom sent
in the artwork as you can and take a
look at it and Tommy used to pencil in
link his own stuff he was okay to me he
was Tom Chuck was okay he was okay he
was okay and then there's this one issue
I think it was Marvel premiere number 50
it was the one where Alice Cooper is in
the insane asylum and they've said Tom
we're gonna let Terry Austin ink it and
it's goal it is and I go
he just took Tom Sutton I thought I knew
Tom Sutton's art there you go and he
just morphed it and I went oh my god oh
my god this is before art Adams comes on
and blows our minds with something like
long shot yes and that book has got all
this stuff and I just go I know there's
some of that and most of it maybe was
Tom Sutton but the clarity of all of it
was Terry ossicles terrorize coming
Tom's
Sutton look that good yeah shoot he can
make my mom look good
right we're good we're good it's like
it's all about visuals it's it's what
visually are you doing that turns us on
that's what we are attracted to period
in a story looks at characters looks of
art that's you know let's not kid
ourselves and I swear to you we artists
in every field don't get enough
attention we just do not whether they're
designing the Millennium Falcon or the
spawn or whatever man that the art if it
doesn't look cool we don't even give it
a second glance and that's what we're
what we're talking about is what's cool
I know what's cool and he said the word
I have a complete bias to that work I
that that I've been in been I've been
sitting here next to Stanley and they're
like hey how comes spider-man so popular
and we're getting to this that's the
terror conversation I usually don't jump
in and then you're sitting there
sometimes you're sitting there going hey
what makes Batman soap operas worth and
right and it's like one of them which is
odd to me is like well he's a human and
he's just like us and he's got flaws and
he's Peter Park and he's your age and
all this doesn't he's so relatable okay
doesn't explain Bruce Wayne right who's
the exact opposite of everything you
just said there is one commonality
between the two them they're both cool
Ava bad is it ten year old kids eight
year old kid you're not thinking about
whether I relate to that guy or whether
that other guy is a multi-millionaire
you're going to one guy can climb walls
super cool and the other guy sits around
till 3 o'clock in the morning puts on
this dark bat costume and to go to
scares the crap out of the bad guys
super super Courtney didn't have any
super powers on top of it so he's a dude
on top of like every eight 10 12 year
old kid understands cool and the rest of
it is us adults trying to dissect what
is instinctively you already know the
Millennium Falcon just has a wicked
design to it right the represent us I
saw it with the neck and the 2p I'm
going who's thought of that and whether
it can fly or whether the the
engineering of it all work I don't care
I mean they just did I was at a gala
yesterday Batman where they unveil his
Batman black on my statue that was based
on a cover I did for a Batman for 23 and
one of the things that had to happen
when we first started it was it's big
graphic image a Batman he's sort of
cuddling
a woman and then one what's Batman doing
underneath the Cape got to tell you did
that draw on 30 years ago never gave it
a second thought
right we are trying to do covers that
will stand out images that will stand
out and for me all's I was looking for
was to just go
what graphically will grab your
attention and I don't worry about the
reality we're doing comic books we're
not doing reality kill you want better
on this I'm laughing looking at all your
photos last night and I go Todd
McFarlane if I am if you want to correct
me
you let you correct me Todd McFarlane
did two issues a Batman two three three
two oh three please about me three
issues a Batman and the dude has a
sculpture that like you know I know but
but three issues and a couple covers and
got a celebrated statue you want to know
why because you go that's cool
and and are good I know what that image
looks like exam and I'm gonna I'm gonna
use the f-bomb it's [ __ ] yeah it's
like the cape or that cape looks awesome
right and to somebody from from Warner
Bros we're saying have you seen some of
the websites where they're talking about
like what's Batman doing and it's
incorrect and it's incorrect and it's
incorrect and I'm because here's what I
know I made a career on this character
called spider-man no human being can go
into the poses that I put spider-man in
but it looks cool that's right and
here's what here's what here's what I
try not to forget and I've just had the
conversation with Scott Campbell and
with a great cou pool when because they
were doing some work for me on bond 300
I go I only need one thing from both you
gentlemen
remember the 15 year old Greg Capullo
and remember the 15 year old Scotty
Campbell because we're going what do you
want kind of covers you want the one
that the 15 I'm talking to Scott
Campbell hey Todd what kind of cover you
want the one that the 15 year old Scott
Campbell would and so that's the cover
and these guys are trying to give way
too much intelligence to something
forgotten they're in or do actually
going into the subject that I want to
talk about specifically comic book
covers yeah both of you guys have done
killer covers and some together yeah the
best ones good job so talk for the ones
that you've actually done what are some
of your like name two or three that you
for you guys you just you think they're
maybe your best work or things
you think we're just i conic are you
super happy with them and I'm also
curious how long does it actually take
you guys to do some of these covers in
terms of and and maybe how the ideas
germinate or you know what I mean you
know for me it would be young but number
one them on a mound yeah New Mutants 98
it's just a great you get the the
duality of the figure stand in there and
then the reaction of the characters and
then the one we did together that
honestly is one of my favorites and
people now recreate it with action
figures it's cable horses Wolverine and
Todd inked it and I mean again there was
a lot of clash covers and I was like how
do I do this how they did so I put
Wolverine high in the air coming down on
cable and it's just to this day I have
people who are like this is my favorite
cover and it's got a lot of motion
they're all different well two of them
are pretty stayed pretty pretty solid
and then the one is very action-packed
those are the three that I dig the most
I'm pretty sure this guy's got one that
I can think of spider-man 3 I don't know
what he's gonna say
I wouldn't put for me I wouldn't put
spider-man 300 there
I know it's it's made its mark but there
are some its iconic the Wolverine one
with no background he's just going
screaming at you and I get some
reflection in the blades don't know why
that took off so much - I just felt
there's this really it's clean and it's
simple so to me it's more graphic but
I'd go wow that one took off I I would
say spider my number one you know I was
going I want something and I'm gonna put
all the webs in it so that it just is an
interesting image to look at right I
would even say here's the thing that's
weird when I look back at even like the
cover to spawn one it's not my best
write about it but because it's the
number one it becomes sort of more
important visually the people than it is
to me I did a lot of covers post that
that I thought were way better that I go
huh
I in my run a Spider Man there are some
that I did with the with the Green
Goblin and the Hobgoblin and the Ghost
Rider that I thought compositionally
were sort of cool you know I just went
wow this came out better than I thought
in my head
and you know every now and then you get
those moments for I but I can honestly
say not just because you sitting here I
I think some of the best covers I've
inked that weren't my own because when
you're doing your own you do this
shorthand were the ones I did over over
Rob right there were at that point for
whatever we had to some pattern oh it
was awesome he would he would give me
these pages and he would go like this
and it would JIT and he and he sort of
had this pencil style that was mine so
it was just super easy to adapt and it
was still all robbed like you never
looked at any of those covers and what
that wasn't robbed right and then a
little bit later this new guy comes
along into my life called Greg Capullo
and Greg Capullo was like Rob which is
I'm gonna give you all the form and I'm
gonna give you all the information but
I'm not gonna be so rigid with what the
way I'm throwing down the lines that you
can't come in there and just do a little
bit have a little bit of fun and I've
always told me when I think I'm not
trying to make it fun so that it looks
like my stuff I'm saying you give me
five lines in your hair I'll put ten oh
I'm gonna actually completely jump on
this and tell you as up so getting inked
by Todd early and then inked by Todd a
few years ago on a couple covers I was
like I mean I know what Todd is gonna do
I'm gonna anticipate so I put all these
lines here I'm put all these lines here
he will find more lines and more like
you said you've got three lines I'll
make that ten dude can detail up the
most deep you can't possibly give and it
is it's awesome to watch it's awesome
we're running out of time and I want to
make sure that I get the answer so for
you guys how long does it typically take
for a cover and what is it like in terms
of okay so you're sitting down to do
whatever issue we're talking about is it
your your your thinking in your brain
what are you trying to come up with are
you sketching how does that come about
so how does it come about for you in the
creation process typically and how long
does it usually take we did deadlines a
cover a cover was a day yeah you got to
come up with it and you got to live with
it very quickly and then you got to put
it down on paper and you got to get it
done and all of a sudden at the end of
the day you got to put it in FedEx so
sometimes you had the luxury of two days
but
it's a day job a page yeah let me tell
you anybody in our industry you do I've
got a prayer and I'm not religious but I
got a prayer a page a day Monday through
Friday
take the weekends off a page a day
Monday through Friday take the weekends
off a page a day Monday through Friday
take the weekends off you will then have
300 issues of your own comic book that's
how you get there
hey good good I don't know we need to
make spawn 300 the number one seller I'm
telling you right now like it's exciting
three hundred issues a spawn I mean one
makes the record I literally I told you
I want to come and celebrate spawn 300
that this is a huge milestone I am so
I'm proud of him but I'm I'm blown away
that the the dedication Todd said 25
years ago I'm gonna do this every month
and no one else did no one took it
mysteriously Eric Eric's right behind
him but that but you're you're you paste
it you get it three hundred is 301 is an
enormous number and listen I am a comic
fan I am a peer I am amazingly impressed
honored to be your buddy
and congratulations three hundred men
that is sick it's sick I can't wait for
come out I cannot wish my go when ever
comes out and buy all the covers that I
can afford and and get that chase and
all you know it's exciting and I can't
wait to officially announce Rob and I
recreating all those Marvel covers that
we did together has parodies for spawn
okay I mean I actually yes I'd be all in
on that right I honestly have so many
other questions but um we're basically
out of time and I'm just gonna say at
some point in the future I would
sincerely love to continue talking as a
fan and I I thank you so much for
sharing this extravagant for real it's a
real thrill to sit down with the two of
you I just say thank you honestly
sincerely Rockway thank you everybody I
really appreciate it